tu sais où on a le plus de chance de
voir Christine Kristen Stewart
Antoine tu savais que Emile avait vécu
entre 1840 et 1902 enfin dans ces
eaux-là
tu sais aussi que Émile a eu la
varicelle
Émile zona
qu'est-ce que je pense de ce maillot je
me trouve
champêtre je pense que ça veut dire mais
non écoute esthétique agréable et
soyeux il est un peu grand non ça c'est
pas
très bien
donc le ballon il manque le ballon
regarde
salut les amis on est sur le montage
d'alibi.com 2 le montage d'une phase
très importante du film c'est important
notamment de toujours choisir les bonnes
prises pour mettre en valeur les acteurs
et les actrices du film
c'est du sable mouvant